Hi, I'm Monica, the beauty expert.
I'm Ashley, the coordination maven.
And today, we're gonna help one woman
avoid a quarter-life crisis.
(music)
Patrice, tell us about
your quarter-life crisis.
I recently got a job as a producer.
Congratulations.
- Awesome.
- Yeah, right.
I'm, like, girl power.
But I just feel like I
wanna be taken seriously.
I feel like there are a couple
of challenges with that.
One, I look really young.
I noticed that, if I look like a kid,
people treat me like a kid.
Usually, I'm a lot more street,
kind of workout clothes.
Do you feel like you have any pieces
that are a little more, like, business-y?
I do, and they literally
have cobwebs on them
because I haven't had to wear
them in such a long time.
So...that's where I need you guys' help.
Well you sound super ready.
You're doing the work on the inside;
it's time to address the outside.
So, we're coming over.
- Oh, great!
- We're gonna come
to your space.
And declutter and organize.
Leave it the way it is, be
yourself, and just let us
help you upgrade it a little bit.
Great.
- We're coming over.
- You get to see the real.
We're coming over.
Okay.
(music)
You have so much to work with already.
Just like, right off the bat.
You're already so close to
where you're tryin' to be.
So, I definitely have so
tips and ideas for you.
So, my skin care, I
would love to talk about.
Because I literally just wash
my face with a soy cleanser,
and then I don't do anything else.
Cause I have really oily skin.
You are saying that you
don't own any moisturizer?
That is correct.
- I knew you were going to...
- What?
...say that. (laughs)
I understand like having oily skin,
it feels super
counter-intuitive to put product
on top of that.
- Yeah.
But actually, moisturizer
like, it keeps the oil
in your skin and keeps you hydrated.
So, I have a product that
I'm gonna recommend to you.
It's the Olay Total Effects
7 In One moisturizer.
Yeah.
This will keep it simple and
get you everything you need.
Oh yeah, oh firmness.
Girl.
(laughs)
So this is my work space.
It's a little crazy,
but I kind of wanted to
let you see that, 'cause that's the real.
There's a lot of clutter.
Decluttering is an
opportunity for you to get out
of your own way and fully step
into where you're headed now.
So this is my closet.
I like a lot of pinks.
Hoodies.
I always go right to the
three steps I follow.
Which is to sort, purge, then organize.
So I would want to sort
so that you can know your inventory.
And be able to make
those outfits so easily.
And then you can pull from each side.
Like this is my professional side;
this is my everyday side.
But every once in a while,
you'll be able to mix the two sides.
Yeah.
So if they're separated,
you'll be able to see that right away.
(upbeat music)
This is day seven that I'm using it,
and I feel like a lot of
the dark spots on my face
are lightening up.
I also, like that it's kind of
like a whipped, soft feeling.
Like it feels really light and airy.
But, it does like absorb into my skin,
and then I can put my makeup
on, and I feel good, guys.
(string music)
Oh, that's gross.
I'm already feeling
better about this because
it's just less stuff
for my eyes to look at.
(string music)
This is what I ended up in today.
It doesn't really feel
like me, but I'm trying.
I'm off to this meeting.
I did my hair.
And I forgot my production
notebook, great.
(upbeat music)
How are you doing?
It's been good.
I've been working on my skin,
using the moisturizer from Olay.
I usually have dark spots right here,
and it's just feeling more even.
With the wardrobe, I feel like,
I might need a little bit more work on.
(laughs)
I feel like it takes a lot of time.
It has been kind of crazy, you guys.
I'm excited about working this much,
but I realize I get on set and I look
so tired.
Well, I think I may
have something for that.
It's an eye gel from Olay.
Yes, and it's going to
help with your tired eyes.
If you say it's good, it's good.
'Cause the moisturizers
worked, I trust you.
You got this.
I've been working pretty
hard at declutter, and
it feels good.
That's my zen zone - still pretty zen.
But now, it leads into my workspace.
We organized all the crap. It's all gone.
This has really been helping
me feel very organized.
Because I feel like, at home,
I'm ready to rock, even before I leave.
It's bee kind of a long week.
So I'm trying this under-eye gel.
Wow.
Feels actually really cool.
All right, so Patrice,
how do we think she did?
I'm curious to see how she did
with all the stuff we gave her.
I'm actually now just realizing
how much work we gave her.
(laughs)
- Did we? I hope we didn't
give her too much.
No, she can handle it.
- She's like...
- Yeah.
...got a really good
head on her shoulders.
She's ready for this new
job and whatever it takes.
(music)
All right Patrice, let's go.
We wanna see it.
Wooo. (women in unison)
Wooo, look at her.
- Yes, Patrice.
- Whoa.
I like that she is still playful
because that's who she is.
And she doesn't feel like stiff
or like she can't be herself.
Also, literally, look at her skin.
Glowing.
- She's super glowing.
- It's literally glowing.
She didn't even have a moisturizer
when we started this.
Oh my gosh, wow.
(laughs)
Oh my goodness.
It's so cute.
This is awesome.
She's really finding herself in her space
in a good way.
That's gonna support her
visions and her dreams.
She's not going to be distracted
by all that clutter anymore.
I'm bout to...kill this.
Go Patrice.
Go us.
It was a great meeting today.
I just had a great day in general.
I felt good, and I still feel like me,
but I feel professional.
I don't feel like I
have to be embarrassed,
when I walk into a place.
Yeah, this was a great experience.
Another quarter-life crisis averted.
Cheers to that.
(glasses clinging together)
(upbeat music)